Leonardo DiCaprio. You were one of the first people to work with him.
How old was he in "This American boy"?
"This boy's life", pardon.
Was he about 14 or 13 or 14?
Young.
It must be amazing to see, you know, to watch his career.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah
Leo was also - we had a reading of the movie and
Leo wasn't reading the lead. It was another kid and and at the end of it I said
"This kid is interesting, you know.
You should che- you know, pay more attention to him."
And I don't know whether that
My saying that had anything to do with it, but that was-
You know it did.
Anointed by Robert De Niro. Other kids. Who knows where they are now.
Someone else though. Someone else had a huge influence on Leonardo DiCaprio's career. I turn to Paul Rudd.
(laughs)
You did, though. You properly did.
I don't know, I don't think I had an influence. But, I sometimes I, you know, looking back
find yourself in some interesting conversations and moments in time and
I worked with Leonardo on Romeo and Juliet.
And at the time, my father
made his living. He was a Titanic expert and he used to take people all over the world
talking about Titanic. He could go to universities.
-Yeah, yeah.
It was my last day of filming
Romeo and Juliet and we all went out to a bar afterward. All the guys...
We were all a bunch of guys working on the movie
And so we were in different cars and I was riding to the place with Leo and he said, "I just got offered this movie
And it's a big movie". He had done indie films to that point. He said "it's a big, it's a studio movie. It's Titanic".
And I said "That's incredible!" and I knew a lot about Titanic because my dad just talks about Titanic
And we just had a conversation about it and
He was saying like, "I don't know what I'll do". I remember saying: "You should do it!"
I don't think I had any say, but it is kind of interesting to think back on that.
Yeah, there was a moment when he might never done it. -Yeah, cause he didn't. He didn't do the movie.